EMMA DONOGHUE:
Thank you very much.
It's a thrill to be here.
Your smoothies are
fantastic I'm going
to read just a couple of
pages from this, because what
I really love is answering
questions and chatting,
so I don't want
to read too long.
But on the other hand,
I love giving readings,
so I couldn't quite
do without that.
I wrote "Frog Music"
because about 15 years ago I
came across a particular
unsolved murder.
And there's a lot of unsolved
murders in the world,
you can't worry
about them too much,
but this particular one
was about 27 year old
frog catcher you made her living
collecting sacks of live frogs
and delivering them to
San Francisco's Chinese
and French restaurants.
And to do this
she wore trousers,
and that means she got
arrested roughly once
a month under San
Francisco's little
known anti cross-dressing laws.
So she's the kind
of character who,
if you dropped her on the
streets of San Francisco now,
she wouldn't turn a--
nobody would bat an eyelid.
That's the metaphor
I'm looking for.
But in 1876, her
attitude towards gender,
her playful, individualistic, do
your own thing kind of attitude
was unprecedented.
She never disguised
herself as a man,
she just swaggered around town
in her pants and her pistol,
which in fact she'd taken out
on a kind of hired purchase
from a pawn broker.
It didn't even belong to her.
And somebody shot her
through a window at 27.
And the other woman in the
room who emerged unscathed
was this French erotic
dancer called Blanche Beunon
I'm going to read you a
little scene where Blanche
is she's performing on stage at
the house of mirrors bordello.
Here we go.
"Blanche goes to stand
outside the stage door,
recognizing the final thumps
of Fabienne's flamenco
skipping rope act.
The piano has been tuned,
which is some relief to her.
Blanche goes over her
routines in her head,
trying to block out the
sound of Madame's hushed,
thrilling voice as
she warms the crowd up
for the enigmatic
Blanche le Danseuse.
Blanche opens the stage
door a crack to check
whether the lights have gone
low, and she waits for silence.
The excited battle
of the audience
dies away in the near dark.
Blanche walks out
onto the stage,
as formal as some courtier,
and a storm of applause
rises when the lights flare up.
Blanche averts
her face from them
until the cheering subsides.
She makes a rapid scan
of the whole room.
Not a single red
velvet chair is empty.
The tune is a nervous
tarantella, slow at first,
and then it starts to
hurry, and Blanche twitches.
This one's a simple routine,
no intricate steps to remember
or fleets of
flexibility to perform.
Blanche simply pretends
there's something
in her clothes, flea, spider,
skeeter, bee, wasp, it really
doesn't matter as long as she
imagines it vividly enough.
And the music is half
the trick of this one.
Stop and start,
itchily agitated,
then more, and more maddened
as the invisible parasite
starts to bite.
Madame has always advertised
Blanche the lively flea
as having the speciality
of the tarantella
straight from gay
Paris, and in June
when some girl over
on California street
started doing the dance, Madame
sent a bouncer over to put paid
to that.
But the fact is, Blanche
picked the gist of this act
up from another show girl
who spent only a few weeks
at the house of mirrors
before heading off to Chicago.
The only difference is
that Blanche plays it
for earnest, not for laughs.
Tonight, what she
pictures up her skirts
is one of those vicious
mosquitoes from San Miguel
station.
So she flinches, twists,
spins around on herself.
Her fingers pursue the
invisible invader up her gloves,
down her neck, under
her sweeping black hem.
Every customer in
the house must be
able to imagine
where the bug has
got to, every fold and crevice.
The tarantella is driving
Blanche out of her mind now,
and she's peeling her gloves
off and flinging them away
towards the audience.
Her own hands molesting
her, plunging up her skirt,
raking her thighs,
clawing at her skin
as if she wants to shed it.
She's not even wearing
flesh colored tights tonight
because she has
broken with protocol,
and her pale flawless
legs are bare,
and her eyes are terrified.
She wrenches off the
little bolero jacket,
hearing a seam rip.
She fights her hair in it's
[INAUDIBLE] till it falls down.
She tears the black satin
bodice open down the middle,
and fake pearls explode onto
the boards of the little stage.
Some of the men in the
audience look more alarmed
than aroused, it
occurs to Blanch,
but does she give
a good goddamn?
She goes into one
last fit of frenzy
and collapses in the
middle of the stage.
Woo hoo!
Men are throwing up their
hats and catching them,
roaring Blanche,
Blanche, Blanche!
She waits for the
clamor to die away.
Do they like her like this,
laid low, hair in her eyes,
coal halfway down
her cheeks, kneeling
in a plain corset and drawers
like any destroyed woman.
The professor's eyes at the
piano are as neutral as ever.
He gives Blanche that private
nod that means, ready?
And then he launches into
the simple, jolly chords
of her last number.
Rage, Blanche recognizes
the feeling of last.
Rage, and deep down revulsion,
at the prospect of spending
another night of her life
turning this old crank.
She summons her
forces and stands,
hand on her hip like some
slap dash street walker.
I wish I was the diamond--
she begins sweetly.
I wish I was a diamond
upon my Lulu's hand,
and every time I
wiped my ass, I'd
see the promised land, oh lordy.
Her gestures are broad, clownish
now, and the men love it.
For the chorus, she
throws out her arms,
conducting the audience
like an orchestra.
Bang away Lulu, bang
anyway good and strong.
Oh what'll we do for
a damn good screw
when our Lulu's dead and gone."
I'll leave that there.
[APPLAUSE]
EMMA DONOGHUE: One of the
hardest things to research
for this book was to find out
what exactly erotic dancers did
in the 1870s.
You might think it's pretty
obvious what erotic dancers do,
but no, they did not strip.
They didn't take off
their clothes bit by bit.
They did not pole dance.
Nobody had invented
the poll dance.
So it was very hard to
find out what they did.
There's a lot of vague
stuff about mysterious women
of eroticism in
previous centuries,
but it was very hard
to find specifics.
And two of the only
specifics I did
find where this Tarantella
thing, this bug up the skirt
dance that seems the oldest
form of erotic dance known.
I mean, maybe the fact that
they were all flea infested,
they just decided to
make a virtue of that.
[LAUGHTER]
EMMA DONOGHUE: I cannot imagine
thrilling an audience nowadays
by pretending that
you're infested.
We just have
different standards.
And another kind
of dance they did
a lot was the skirt
dance where they
would have this huge
skirt, 44 feet around,
and they would hide in the
skirt, make a butterfly of it,
make a screen of it, and then
at the end they would undo
the skirt and have it
swoop over the audience.
I decided that I didn't know
whether these dancers sang,
but there were so
many good songs
around that I decided we have
to include some songs in it.
I had to find out of copyright
texts for all the songs, which
proved very difficult.
Because often, some lyrics
just float around online.
And everyone says, oh yeah,
here's an old version.
And you're thinking,
how old is that version.
I need specifics.
There's a great folk
music site, called Mudcat,
where all these really geeky
guys share their knowledge.
And they're like,
that's the 1921 version,
you're mistaking
it for the 1922.
[LAUGHTER]
EMMA DONOGHUE:
It's just fantastic
getting to suck the brains
from geeky guys online.
They're just so happy to
share their knowledge.
So I found really early
versions for most of the songs,
but that Lulu song was almost
impossible to track down
because it was a dirty song.
And some of the later
versus are far worse.
And because it was rude,
before the 20th century
nobody would write it down.
They'd say things like,
and of course, we all
know the notorious Lulu song.
And I'd say, no we don't.
Give me details.
And then finally,
in the 1960s, bless
him, one particular editor
of a book of dirty songs,
he not only published
the text, but he
said at the start-- I always
imagined he was smoking pot
at the time-- this
book copyright free,
share the songs.
And then I noticed in the second
edition his publisher was like,
all applications must be
sent in writing to us.
This book is copyright-- I had
a copy of the first edition
with this lovely
hallucinogenic cover.
I finally got a copyright-free
version of Lulu.
There are also many sad
things in this book.
It's not all fun
and games obviously.
San Francisco was having
a particularly hard summer
in 1876.
I didn't need to
make any of this up.
It was having a record
heat wave, which is unusual
for San Francisco.
Ice would fall off
carts in the street
and children would surround
it and lick the blocks.
And they were simultaneously
having a smallpox epidemic,
which usually was
a winter thing.
So they were just
having a cursed season.
And, as you can probably
tell, I absolutely
loved immersing myself in
this strange, and sticky,
and unhygienic world.
Questions please.
Questions about anything.
AUDIENCE: Well,
I will start off.
I wanted to know, when you
were in your college career,
and then graduate
career, did you
think that you were
going to be an historian,
or did you know that you were
going to be a writer, as well,
of literary stuff.
And did you plan to
merge those two things?
EMMA DONOGHUE: Sure.
I thought I was going to
be a professor of English.
My dad, Dennis Donoghue,
who taught at NYU
until last year, he's
a professor of English,
and I thought I was
going to be one too.
I now realize that would have
been a doomed plan, because I
would've been the less
famous professor of English.
You should really try not
to follow your parents
into any line of work.
But I thought that's what I
would do, because I thought,
well, at least then I
can read books all day
and write books at night.
I think in fact,
I would have been
a very discontented
professor of English.
And you know the better kind
is always saying to students,
well I did an hour
of office hours,
but now I'm writing my novel.
I didn't think I would be a
historian because, growing up
in Ireland, I
thought history was
the tale of the many pathetic
little revolutions we had.
Every few years we'd rise up and
the English would gun us down.
And I just thought
that's what history was.
I hadn't quite clicked that
social history is history too.
But anyway, then
I started writing
novels when I was about 20
during my undergrad degree.
And my mother was
like, couldn't you
get your exam first
and then your novels?
And I was like, no, can't
wait, inspiration is knocking.
And I managed to sell two
novels when I was about 23,
and then I thought, maybe I
could just not have a job.
I could just write.
How cool would that be?
And somehow, at 44, it has
worked, so far at least.
And yeah, so I've never had,
not just a nine to five job,
but any kind of
job where you have
to turn up and do what
anybody else tells you to.
Never.
Somehow got away without it.
Which means that when I'm
writing contemporary fiction,
I have difficulty describing
real jobs for my character.
So I have to say to
friends, what's it like?
What time do you have to
get up in the morning?
You have to shower every day?
[LAUGHTER] But you
probably don't have to
at Google, do you?
So yeah.
In a way, I'm an
academic gone wrong.
And I think my academic
training has left me
with not only a profound
interest in research,
and getting things right.
I absolutely love
the forensic task
of making a book
like "Frog Music"
true as much as I can make
it, as well as fiction.
You've got these two
loyalties, these two jobs.
I would say there are about 26
characters in "Frog Music" who
are real people from the time.
Often all I know
is one tiny thing,
like one particular
French prostitute
in the gold rush, Maria la
Forge, she got in a fight
with her pimp and he
threw acid at her,
which was the crime of the day.
That was very common
in those days.
She had half a face.
I just thought,
she's irresistible,
I have to include her as an
older woman in my novel set
20 years later
wandering around San
Francisco with
this mangled face.
I'm not suggesting that
I'm able to completely
conjure these people up as
they were, but give them
at least a moment in
the spotlight again.
I always assume
they're grateful,
because otherwise they would
be completely forgotten.
Whereas if you're writing
about really famous people
from the past, you might
feel that they're like,
don't bug me.
Don't dig me up again.
But the kind of obscure
nobody's and oddities
that I write about,
I always assume
they're grateful for
a little attention.
You know?
AUDIENCE: So how do
you write? [INAUDIBLE].
Given that you don't
have to get up at 6:30
and get on the train.
What do you actually do?
EMMA DONOGHUE:
Well, a great thing
that structures the
day is children.
So, I used to be able
to write any old time,
so sometimes I'd find it
a bit hard to get started.
But now, when my kids are
deposited on the school bus,
I just feel this
surge of adrenaline.
They're gone, I can write.
And so I run to my desk, and
these days I run at my desk
as well because I use a
treadmill for about half
the day.
And again, it'll be not
that exciting to you,
but in the writing
world it's fairly freaky
still to use a treadmill.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, we have a few
of those around the building.
EMMA DONOGHUE: Yeah.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
EMMA DONOGHUE: Fantastic.
You see, I hate exercise.
So the idea that I can be
exercising without knowing it
while I'm writing is fantastic.
For the first year I was
getting static shocks
because nobody had told me
about antistatic bracelets.
I should have asked earlier.
I just thought it was
part of the process.
[LAUGHTER]
EMMA DONOGHUE: And so yeah.
So I would say the day
alternates between sitting down
writing, standing up writing.
And I do a huge
amount of planning.
I use a really good Apple
program, a program for Mac
called Scrivener.
I used to use Word, and
so I'd write my novel
in one huge, long Word file.
And then I'd go, where is
the bit about the dog, search
for the dog, cut
and paste sections,
occasionally forgot to
paste a section and lose it.
I know this sounds
silly, but Scrivener
lets you write in lots of
tiny, little postcard chunks
and then move them around.
So, for instance,
I started writing
this book in chronological
order from when
Blanche and Jenny, and all their
friends meet in the summer,
through to Jenny's
murder and the aftermath.
I'm not giving too
much away because Jenny
get's killed in the first page.
And so I was writing it that
way, and then I thought,
you know, it feels
too undramatic
just starting with
them making friends.
I want to start with
blood on the floor,
and then cut back and forward.
And so I was able to just
move all the scenes around
like a puzzle pieces.
So I'm a big planner,
and sometimes
when I'm describing this to
audiences of book lovers,
they look at me like,
how coldblooded you are.
But to me, it's like you
wouldn't try and plan
a building without blueprints.
You wouldn't just say, oh,
let's just get creative
and build it from the ground
up, because it would fall down.
And some of my books
would fall down
if I didn't do a
lot of planning.
And in particular I'm
not very good at plots.
I can do dialogue till
the cows come home.
I'm sort of natural
with characters,
but plotting, and in particular
suspenseful plotting,
doesn't come naturally to me.
So I do a lot of
planning, because if I
have got a chart of what happens
in each chapter and each scene,
then I can easily see that
it's a big problem when nothing
happens in chapter three,
nothing real happens.
There are no revelations,
no major changes.
And I say to myself, let's
not have a chapter three,
let's just cut it.
So that kind of planning,
I think for the last
maybe about four
books, has really
helped me tighten
the narrative thread.
Whereas I think
some writers just
do that at an unconscious level.
The writers who say that
they just sit down and start
on page one, and they don't
know where they're going,
I think in the
back of their minds
they must somehow know
where they're going.
But I need an actual blueprint.
And of course, you can still
change things as you go along.
Just because you've
committed yourself
to the bar fight in chapter
six, it doesn't mean,
when you get there, you can't
have a love scene instead.
AUDIENCE: Do you do all
the research first then?
EMMA DONOGHUE: I do a lot
first but then-- Of course, I
don't use most of it.
So I'm just looking for that
one bizarre little detail.
And so it's not like
researching for-- If you're
writing an article
about a place,
you feel obliged to tell
people all about the place.
I'm more like, what's the
one, little, odd thing?
So I do a lot beforehand,
then I start to story plan.
For instance, one of
the newspaper articles
I found about
Jenny had mentioned
that when the press had caught
up with Blanche's boyfriend
Arthur, he had a couple
of poxs on his face
from a recent
outbreak of smallpox.
And I thought, oh, did
they have that at the time.
So next thing I knew, I was
planning an entire chapter
in which Arther nearly
dies of smallpox.
So the story sort of arises
naturally out of the research.
So then I start
drafting it, and I
have to stop constantly to do
more research as I go along.
And on the research
involved a lot of pictures
this time, a lot of photographs
of San Francisco, architecture
that just all crumbled away
in the earthquake in 1906.
Lots of, say, promotional
postcards of burlesque dancers.
Because nobody was keeping
detailed accounts of what they
did, so you have to deduce
it from their crazy costumes.
You know, girls wearing horses
heads, and bows and arrows,
and breast plates, and ofter
quite playful military stuff.
They'd have a jacket
with frogging on it,
and military stripes,
and then no skirt.
So you had to deduce a
lot from the pictures.
So some of the amazing
photographs of Eadweard
Muybridge, he'd had some
almost stop motion one's he
would take.
He'd rig up a string
and take 20 pictures
over three seconds of,
either a horse most famously,
or of a woman carrying
a towel or something.
So yeah, I love the research.
I don't find that
it gets in the way.
So long as you ruthlessly drop
anything that doesn't fit.
I really don't
like any paragraph
in a book that sounds
like the author is
stopping to educate you.
So if my point of view
character wouldn't
care what political party
has won the election,
then I don't mention it.
AUDIENCE: Anyone else have
a few questions or comments?
Come on.
Googlers are not this shy.
AUDIENCE: So with
"Room," which, I'm sure
you've gotten this question
before, you have children
so-- although I have children,
I wouldn't be able to do it--
but I'm assuming that helped
in the five year old's voice.
I thought what was interesting
was not so much the lack self
pity, because he had no idea
why he would pity himself
through the whole thing, but
it's after they were escaped,
and for him this new freedom
wasn't really freedom.
How were you-- the adult
and child situations
were flipped in the
real world, so to speak.
I don't have a question.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Talk about that.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Talk about it.
EMMA DONOGHUE: In a way,
what anchored "Room," writing
about such a weird,
one off situation,
is that I kept trying
to think of every day,
normal experiences we've
all had which are like that.
Because Jack goes from
being in a new born
situation, in that he's never
more than a few feet away
from his mother.
She's eternally
available to him.
He's still breastfeeding,
so he's like a newborn.
And then he goes through to
being more like a seven year.
Having to spend lots of time
away from his mother even.
So I kept thinking of what's an
everyday situation like that?
The first time you drop
a kid off at playschool
and you're thinking the
child will be sobbing
and the child walks away
without looking back.
And you think, where's
that intense bond gone.
He just used me.
[LAUGHTER]
EMMA DONOGHUE: So every
parent has got those moments.
Or when you're
playing with a child,
and you're giving
it all you've got
and you think, I'm so magical,
and then they say, I'm bored.
Could we do something else?
Those moments of reversal.
Or I remember one
moment with my daughter
where I briefly
lost her on a cliff.
We were at a monument to
[INAUDIBLE] in France,
and it was this amazing glass
tube heading towards the sea.
So I was having my moment
thinking about [INAUDIBLE]
and then I can't find
my three year old.
And I just completely panicked,
and then I spun around,
and there she was, She
saw I was all shaky
and she was like, it's OK.
I'm right here, it's OK.
And I thought,
she's comforting me.
This is just a bizarre reversal.
And similarly, I
find as adults we
have to explain the rules
of our society to children
all the time, because in
a way, they're always new.
The first time you have
to explain to a child
that things like in
a big supermarket
you can collect everything
and only pay at the end,
but in a shopping mall, even
though there's no actual door,
as soon as you step
out of one little space
and into the corridor
you're shoplifting.
So you have to
remember to pay first.
That rule was actually
explained in the hand book
for new Canadians that I was
given when I moved to Canada.
They're clearly
assuming that you're
coming from some very other
culture where they don't
do shopping malls, and so they
spell all these rules out.
And I remember thinking that
a child wouldn't know that,
so a child would
accidentally shoplift.
A child would hug,
rush towards a dog
and get their hand
bitten as my son did.
And a child would hug somebody
who they're not meant to.
And so I just thought
Jack is just like that,
but he's having to learn
the rules all at once
instead of gradually
over a number of years.
But it was a very
interesting exercise.
It was a defamiliarization
effect on my entire life.
Everything I looked
at, I'd say, wow,
if you'd been living
in a locked room, that
would look very different.
And a lot of it,
a lot of our world
seemed incredibly stressful
from Jack's perspective.
And I put myself in the
book as a bad Starbucks mom.
I have Jack brought
to Starbucks,
and there's moments where he's
noticing some mother who's
fobbing her child off
with a giant cookie
so she can talk to her friends
and check her messages.
I thought, that's
me the part mother
saying leave me alone
so I can write my scene.
[LAUGHTER]
EMMA DONOGHUE: That book made
me feel like such a bad mother.
But luckily, in
this book, Blanche
has a baby she's
very neglectful of,
and I felt like a great
mother compared with her.
So this one was
a real refresher.
[LAUGHTER]
EMMA DONOGHUE: You know,
by 1870s standards,
I'm supreme as a mother.
AUDIENCE: So where did the
idea for "Room" come from.
EMMA DONOGHUE: It happened to be
the Fritzl case in Austria that
inspired it, but I
remember thinking, OK, I
don't want anyone thinking I'm
writing about a real victim
here, that would be tacky.
Because when you write
about people in the past,
that's fine.
They're never going
to knock on your door.
But writing about
real people now,
that would give me the creeps.
So I thought, I'll
set it in America,
very far away from Austria.
In the Fritzl case in
Austria, she and her children
were in an underground dungeon.
And I thought, OK, I'll
make it above ground
in a shed with a sky light.
It'll be totally different.
And then right after
I'd written the book,
Jaycee Dugard was discovered
in a shed in California.
And I thought, you
just can't win.
And then the Cleveland
case happened,
and I had people
blogging saying,
Emma Donoghue must
feel so guilty
that she's inspired this crime.
And I thought, don't tell
me that those monsters read
literary fiction.
I just don't believe it.
I mean, copycats all of
other crimes to copy from.
They don't need to
read novels to do it.
It's funny, you get so used
to a particular subject you're
researching like
smallpox, or infanticide,
that you learn to be able to
talk about it quite flippantly,
and then you suddenly think,
I've just said the word rape
and I'm giggling.
It's awful how you get used
to whatever your topic is.
AUDIENCE: What's
coming up next for you.
What are you working on now?
Well you see, with
"Frog Music" I
set myself the challenge
of making it a real murder
mystery, as well as
a literary novel.
I thought the mystery
side of it has to work,
because people who like
crime, they read it a lot,
and they're very sophisticated
readers of crime,
and they do not want you to
make some pathetic, halfhearted
attempt at crime.
It's got to work.
And there's a kind of a
contract with the reader.
And similarly, I
found it so enjoyable
to have that particular kind of
gun to my head, at every point
I was like, will the crime
fans be happy enough?
Will they accept it
as a crime novel?
Now I'm trying to write
a children's book,
and that's way scarier,
because a lot of writers
think, oh, I've
written for adults.
I can write for children.
Or, oh, I'm a mom, I
can write for children.
But I don't assume that
any of these things
give me the ability
to write for children.
And so, in another month I
have to submit the first draft
to my son and his
two best friends.
[LAUGHTER}
EMMA DONOGHUE: I'm terrified.
So I've written up a
reader's report for them
to fill in for me.
I'm trying to give
them questions
that won't hurt my feelings.
So I don't at any point
say, do you like this book?
I say things like,
which character did you
find most interesting?
But of course, they could still
subvert this by going, none.
Because kids just have no tack.
So I'm nervous about that,
but on the other hand
I'm planning a five book series.
So I'm very
confident in one way.
Or rather, with every
book, I've found
that if you just, from
the very beginning,
assume it will be published in a
lovely cover and given a title,
and even write those
blurbs on the jacket.
I write them very early
on before the book.
[LAUGHTER]
EMMA DONOGHUE: It's like, if I
fake it, somebody will make it,
you know.
I'll call it a room, and I'll
even talk about it in public
to Googlers, and
therefore it will happen.
AUDIENCE: So, does
anybody else have anything
they would like to add
or ask or anything?
We do have McNally
Jackson in the back
with us-- yay-- to have
copies of both "Frog
Music" and "Room."
These are the
subsidized editions
that you can get for $10 cash.
And maybe Emma will sit
for a few more minutes
and sign copies of them for us.
EMMA DONOGHUE: Sure.
AUDIENCE: So, if anybody
else-- Unless there's
anything else to
ask, let's just hang
out and chat for
a couple minutes.
Thank you Emma.
EMMA DONOGHUE: Thank you.
That was fun.